hello UCLA graduates I welcome you and
your family to the 2017 commencement
ceremony for the College of Letters and
Science
I'm grateful for your commitment to building
a better University for generations that
will follow you
it's time for you to take that same
spirit of determination that love of
community that insatiable need for to
make a better world around you
everywhere you go
Bruins can do anything
despite our differences in ideology upbringing or
beliefs differences that are not walled
off but celebrated and valued here
optimism is the unifying thread that
pushes us to be better versions of
ourselves and achieve great things
you're all going to be tested challenge
the status quo when someone tells you
that you can't prove that you can when
someone tells you that you won't prove
that you will
I hereby confer upon you the degree of
Bachelor of Arts or Bachelor of Science
congratulations